[Musique]
en 2020 sans doute nos journalistes nous
dirons assez belle année 2010 2017 à
cette aile montant en ce temps là il y
avait de l'argent dans ce temps-là
l'industrie française a été très bien
il ya plein d'entreprises qui faisait
10% 20% 30% de croissance
bien sûr tout ce qui est web tout ce qui
est bio technologie la sécurité la
grande distribution le luxe bien sûr
l'aérospatiale et voilà aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons cette vague nous
avons sept la marée montante qui est là
qui est devant nous alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait on y va on jump est en fait
un jean françois dehecq
le président fondateur de sanofi il est
parti de huit personnes et quand il a
quitté 27 ans après il y avait 120 mille
personnes eh bien nous disait on ne
soirées comme ça il ya trois catégories
de personnes
ceux qui sont assis ceux qui sont debout
et ceux qui prennent la mer alors ça
vous dit de prendre la mer le jump est
justement
donc on va voir un petit peu comment
faire d'abord si on veut jump et cadeaux
bord la du plongeoir d'aldo question la
première question c'est où je veux aller
et la deuxième question c'est comment
comment préparer pour que ça se passe au
mieux
alors avant de répondre à ces deux
questions je vous proposais un petit
moment pour se reconnecter avec vraiment
car en soi de ce qu'il peut y avoir de
plus profond de plus naturel et 10 sont
connectés au moment de vie de joie et de
bonheur
je vous invite tout simplement à fermer
les yeux
oui c'est un relais très pratique à
fermer les yeux à bien vous installez
bien confortablement dans votre votre
chaise
et puis en fermant les yeux simplement
en prenant une grande respiration en
lâcher prise sentais vraiment votre
corps de mon très lourds très tranquille
bien posé à votre place
et vous repensé au moment dans votre vie
vous avez été pleinement heureux les
moments de réussite les moments où tout
s'est bien passé où vous étiez à votre
place vous voyez plusieurs situations
comme ça qu'elles soient
professionnelles qu'elles soient pas en
vo étude les bonnes relations avec vos
professeurs avec vos élèves
c'était dur pendant une association avec
des amis il y avait un projet et vous
sentez vraiment tout ce moment de joie
de bonheur ou 700 thuy à votre place
vous êtes sentie complètement aligner
intègre et à maman vous dites waouh ça
j'aime ça j'ai envie de plus j'ai envie
d'aller plus loin
le tout de suite les choses ont pris du
sens et maintenant vous revoyez toute
cette scène où la santé oui les images
santé les sons aux entendez vous
souvenez quelle intuition vous a suivi
pour trouver ce moment de bonheur
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour être
heureux et quelles relations développées
avec les autres personnes
vous avez donné vous avez reçu avec qui
c'était important
vous prenez une grande respiration pour
conserver en vous ces moments de joie
c'est mon autre sens et tranquillement
vous prenez conscience du fauteuil dans
lequel vous êtes assis et tranquillement
vous
venir dans cette salle vous voyez on
sait où on veut aller aux dépens de
henry de crue
mon premier point bas voyez je sais où
je vais aller alors comment c'est quoi
ce lieu on vient de voir un
fondamentalement être heureux
ça passe par une rencontre des
rencontres la rencontre une vraie
rencontre faut sortir le cadre une vraie
rencontre
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que il ya
toujours quelque chose un peu mystérieux
on prévoit quelque chose un objectif
mais il se passe à autre chose
c'est souvent ce qu'on appelle le fit le
fit ça se passe mieux que prévu ce soit
qu'un banquier un investisseur encore
jaar cherche un job quand je veux en
embaucher quand on cherche un partenaire
là soudainement il ya quelque chose qui
me prend et c'est quoi
quelle est la règle là dessus que je
vous propose c'est pas un outil un outil
morale c'est un outil logique je vous
propose tout simplement la sincérité la
sincérité c'est quoi sincérité on n'est
pas chez les bisounours ça on sait bien
sûr qu'il faut se montrer
sur le bas côté vos côtés et un en face
de nous on a souvent aussi un peu des
filous on sait tous à la ccda sincérité
c'est déjà sincérité avec soi même quand
je rencontre quelqu'un est ce que
vraiment ce qui me raconte son projet ce
que je vais faire avec lui pichot
banques les fournisseurs clients
est-ce que se trouve à faire ensemble
des ouaouarons ça c'est vraiment très
chouette
est ce que je ressent dans mes pieds on
dit toujours on pensait que notamment on
pense à nos pieds on sent bien que c'est
au pied qui vont nous aller qui vont
nous guider qui vont nous amener vers
une action c'est pas notre tête à tête
elle vérifie que je marche pas sur un
soin râteau au contraire tout simplement
logique et être sincère c'est sentir ce
qui se passe et il ya une règle aussi
est une loi et de l'humanité pas si mal
fait que ça c'est que justement les
émotions les sentiments sont les choses
les mieux partagées du monde si je sens
que cette personne ni waouh ça fait
pétiller et animaux l'émotion qui monte
il ya beaucoup de chances que sept
personnes ressentent la même chose que
moi et donc du coup à ce moment là whaou
on a envie on a envie d'avancer
donc c'est ça cette société et s'il n'y
avait pas des étoiles dans les yeux ou
quelque sorte et que j'ai vu je vois pas
de mon interlocuteur c'est qu'on est
peut-être à 90% c'est un pro projet oui
c'est bien ça me rassure je gagne
quelque chose qui s'est pas suffisante a
plutôt envie de envie d'avancer
donc c'est ça c'est totti la sincérité
qui me permet de suivre vos intuitions
tout simplement donc premier point pour
aller et trouver le contexte le contexte
où mon talent va pouvoir se développer
comment faire deuxième point comment
faire ben en fait ce qu'on avait invoqué
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que nous
désirons dans la vie fondamentalement on
désire on l'a vu tout à l'heure
plutôt être heureux on a envie sans
doute d'amour on a envie je peins grand
dessinateur
on a envie un peu d'argent on est on est
bien placés ici on a envie d'avoir du
sens dans la vie servir quelque chose
servir tout simplement on a envie de
créer du monde a envie aussi de
d'équilibré entre professionnels et
personnels
on a envie de créer une famille avoir
des enfants c'est un bébé ça
vous retournez vous avez un chien
sauvage qu'on pratique un bref vous avez
la zone de rêve
ça c'est la zone de rêve le rêve c'est
quoi c'est tout simplement ce que je
désire et oui aux et désiré c'est un mot
qu'on ne puisse pas souvent je désire ça
et tout ça c'est quoi bonne j'ai mis des
images vous voyez tout simplement c'est
de l'imaginaire c'est le corps ses
lacunes thème des émotions qui fait
monter kiliwa émotions mot varie en
latin c'est à dire se mouvoir ça me
donne envie d'y aller donc tout
simplement je vais y aller le jeu il a
envie d'aller puis a su recréer ce rêve
donc il va foncer vers ce qu'on pourrait
représenter par une étoile et bien sûr
vous mettez ce que vous désirez sous
cette étoile
donc voilà j'y vais non je fonce et
qu'est ce qui sonne derrière cette
partie et bien pascal on va retrouver
pascal il nous dit c'est la zone de
savoir c'est du savoir en fait
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de la zone
de confort tout bon connaisseur il faut
faire attention à zone de confort c'est
pas forcément confortable
ces annonces et confortable c'est qu'on
la zone de confort sais je sais ce qui
se passe ou tant mieux la zone de savoir
c'est quoi c'est le symbolique c'est le
langage c'est ce qui ce se transmet et
qui me permet de faire ce que j'ai prévu
que je dois faire ce qu'il peut être
bien sûr à nos clients à nos patrons et
aux banquiers et tout se passe comme
prévu
non lui c'est que ça se passe pas tout à
fait comme ça il y à une troisième zone
si si c'est le savoir soyons logique ici
ces inconnus et dans l'inconnu il ya en
effet une troisième zone
il ya plein de trucs là dans l'inconnu
la seule chose que je sais c'est que je
sais pas ce que c'est mais y'a des trucs
et donc là dessus maintenant je me dire
waouh jump et ckoi ben c à d et sortir
de ma zone de confort aller vers
l'inconnu prendre la mer et quand je
suis au bord d'un plongeoir faut
imaginer là où j'ai envie de skier je
suis au départ d'une grande piste il ya
une belle bosse waouh ça vachement envie
j'ai envie donc j'ai plein d'énergie je
ressens la halle envie d'y aller la part
a appuyé en même temps quand je sais je
suis au bord du plongeoir
ben évidemment j'ai un petit peu la
trouille je peux tu envie de quitter
j'ai même envie vraiment de de partir
très vite et j'ai toujours de très
bonnes raisons pourquoi moi
allez mais non après on est à protéger
mme p je bois mon plongeoir je me
concentre j'y vais quand je sors la lors
de mon de la piscine que j'ai plongé une
fois que j'ai sauté la bosse au ski que
la neige plein les oreilles que j'en lis
partout
qu'est ce que je ressens en ce moment là
que ça se passe ce que vous avez
ressenti tout à l'heure tout simplement
c'est ça la joie c'est ça dit waouh mais
ça c'est la vie waouh
j'ai envie d'aller plus bas je fais un
gros plongeon de jeu fait un petit peu
mal joué un peuple un peuple à la neige
est un peu fraîche
waouh mais j'ai envie de plus maintenant
j'ai vraiment envie de faire un saut de
l'ange
maintenant j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose ce que je vous propose c'est que
ce point là c'est ça être vivant le
point de bonheur c'est pas être là en
fait on à pezens suivre l'image c'est
être à se tendre à cet endroit là et là
j'ai vraiment le sentiment d'être vivant
et au passage du col génial pascal et au
passage il ya un truc magique c'est quel
que soit le résultat
ça ça me change quel que soit le
résultat que ces marchés où ce n'est pas
marché vous allez obligatoirement
agrandir votre zone de confort agrandir
votre zone de savoir si vous êtes allé
voir un client et vous dis non une fois
deux fois trois fois
ok vous échangez votre présentation vous
allez voir un coach vous allez voir un
copain et à chaque fois on s'améliore on
s'améliore on s'améliore il ya un moment
donné bien votre produit vous trouver un
investisseur un client un banquier un
partenaire qui fait quoi où la
maintenance a matché la fameuse
rencontre le fit que dans a parlé tout à
l'heure
comment il s'appelle cette partie cette
zone un peu magique passer ça le réel le
fameux réel des scientifiques
toutes les découvertes scientifiques
sont là mais facebook et des oeuvres
d'art
il ya des choses qui sont là qui demande
quelques découvertes qui sont la rmp
c'est osé dire waouh j'ai envie d'y
aller par là et de sauter donc première
conséquence de ce deuxième point sur le
comment y aller comment préparer un
c'est s'autoriser à rêver s'autorise les
arrivées
rêver grand rêver parce qu'on a faim
parce qu'on a envie c'était toi on a
envie de tout ça il n'est écrit nulle
part qu'on n'a pas le droit de tout ça à
la fois simultanément dit waouh comme il
ya des gens qui la vivent pourquoi pas
moi ça devient vraiment très excitant le
deuxième point bien sûr on en parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est oser oser
faire différemment
et quand on ose faire différemment bain
soit il ya un grand vide autour de vous
je passe rien c'est vraiment que ça vous
êtes innovants soit vous êtes beaucoup
de résider résistance et c'est vraiment
si vous êtes sur le bon le bon chemin le
troisième point on parle pas beaucoup
c'est validé validez qu'en fin de
journée si ça a marché on est content
hockey et ou pas toujours en plus mais
validé que quand vous avez passé toute
la journée de difficultés de pépins que
client vous ont dit non que ça pas
marché que l'on gagne pas assez d'argent
et on se dit que le soir
est-ce que j'ai vraiment passé la
meilleure journée de ma vie est ce que
je suis vraiment sur ma voie et qu'on se
dire oui en verseront très chouette ce
que j'ai fait c'est bien la preuve que
vous suivez votre étoile
cette étoile qui est écrit on reçoit
cette étoile qui a envie de se réaliser
on peut plus un talent le génie
intérieur et qui cherche à trouver un
contexte où va pouvoir se régaler voilà
tout simplement le comment aller comment
oser jump est comme ça peut bien se
passer bien se passer dans ce sens où je
suis content de ce que je vais faire je
n'ai pas de baguette magique pour dire
que je vais réussir avec tous les coups
mais en tout et 4 toutes les personnes
qui ont réussi ont essayé ont tenté
m'ont fait mille essais avant militante
ni le même pas et c'est 1000 médiation
et donc les 999 n'ont pas amené grand
chose et la millième a donné un résultat
qu'on connaît donc maintenant une fois
qu'on a compris ça j'ai mon moteur je
les freins
donc il ya plein de métiers une douzaine
de méthode qui nous permet d'accentuer
d'avoir plus d'énergie de pouvoir
avancer
une des méthodes c'est par exemple
d'avoir des toiles très loin jean
françois dehecq parce que j'ai cités
avec sanofi lui ce qui nous dirait dit
moi je supporte pas que les gens soient
malheureux je vois que toute la terre
antienne soit entière soit heureuse
voyez qu'après la fumée avant
c'est quand même grave en ben voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on crée une entreprise
de 120 mille personnes on appelle ça
l'utopie réaliste ça donc avoir un à un
projet qui durera milan peut-être qu'on
va transmettre une autre méthode est osé
dire non
bah oui une fois qu'on a dit non à ce
qui existe au stade comme ça on a du
temps on est disponible on peut avancer
on peut être surpris
une autre méthode une grande méthode qui
marche vraiment très bien que je vous
conseille c'est tout simplement des
petits pas et je suis en venir comme ça
les personnes qui les grands managers
bas souvent ils n'ont pas fait grand
chose de très spectaculaire mais ils ont
fait souvent en permanence et qu'on fait
par des petits pas chaque jour chaque
semaine des choses tranquille sans
risque et ça nous permet d'avancer
tranquillement un grand patron on disait
à son chauffeur
georges rouler doucement nous sommes
pressés voilà pour aller vite raymond
doucement donc voilà c'est pour
introduire cette soirée d'abord où je
veux aller va tout simplement sa
sincérité
est ce que vraiment je suis un endroit
où je me sens bien vous savez vraiment
j'ai envie d'aller vivement demain matin
que j'aime m'amuser autres au travail
conduit en français et de ben justement
osé jump et aux ailes et aux bords et
chaque jour chaque seconde ça qui
devient excitant
qu'est-ce que je pouvoir créer qu'est ce
que je peux voir démarrer qu'est ce que
je vais pouvoir faire de nouveau je vous
garantis par bien sûr d'alexis tout de
suite heureusement au contraire bien au
contraire
ce qui est certain c'est que 100 km 100
% des personnes qui osent dire non à ce
qu'ils leur casser pied qui ose dire oui
à ce qui est vraiment les enthousiastes
à tous les coups vous arrivez à avoir ce
moment où je me sens mal à ma place je
me sois intègre les gens me semble en
communion en communication avec les
personnes que j'ai autour de moi et pour
terminer bien sûr avec pascal il nous
dit que ce que nous avons à gagner
c'est une infinité de vie infiniment
heureuse merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]